What kind of bird are you?
I'm a sparrow, she's a dove.
No, I said,...
...what kind of bird are you?
Dear Suzy, here is my plan.
Dear Sam, my answer is yes.
Dear Suzy, when?
Dear Sam, where?
Dear Suzy, walk 400 yards due north from your house to the dirt path which has not got any name on it,...
...turn right and follow to the end.
I will meet you in the meadow.
Who's missing?
Shakusky, you in there?
Jiminy Cricket, he flew the coop!
Walt, where the hell are you?
Right here.
Does it concern you that your daughter has just ran away from home?
That's a loaded question.
Until help arrives, I'm deputizing the little guy, the skinny one...
...and the boy with the patch on his eye to come with me in the station wagon.
What am I looking at?
He does watercolors, mostly landscapes but a few nudes.
If we find him I'm not gonna be the one who forgot to bring a weapon.
Me neither.
Where's the boy?
I'm told that he's just been struck by lightning.
It's true.
I'll be out back.
I'm gonna find a tree to chop down.